we are very excited this is kind of cool
actually not just because I'm joined as
always by Sonoma Obsession and uh Matt
Gourley hello that was creepy but I
don't I don't know why are you saying
because you do like hello I'm just
trying to like be innocuous so you'll
move on I'm Batman that's not creepy if
I'm Batman that's pretty cool yeah yeah
oh I'm Batman
hey I'm Batman not the same
most nights I'm Batman
that sounds really some nights I'm just
a guy no you got your ruining it I am
Batman no your voice did something I I'm
Batman oh my God help me I'm Batman help
me Batman needs to see an ENT
immediately he's got a large polyp in
his throat what I wanted to mention
before we got off on this whole Batman
stupidity was that uh starting tomorrow
this is exciting starting tomorrow uh
I've and I say I meaning we have a
serious XM channel
Team Coco radio Team Coco radio is going
to be on channel 106. it's just a I
don't know it's very exciting now the
podcast is going to be also streaming on
there at times yes what do you think
that means how do you think that's
different from how people normally
listen to podcast I'm just curious I
have always imagined as you know I'm not
a sophisticated man of the current times
uh I I I
I really because when I think of you I
think of your title being sophisticated
man of the current times
I've always thought when we do the
podcast it always felt to me like it was
just radio so I always Picture People
um listening to the podcast on a
mid-1960s transistor radio live as we
say that live as we say it and they're
walking down the beach and they're
thinking about
um you know are they going to vote for
Muskie in the election or not you know
and so
I've always said
I I don't think about it I you know I
talk into the microphone and then people
on the street seem pleased with what's
happening and so it just seems to me
like it's radio anyway so now and you're
always giving me a hard time because you
love to point out that uh I'm a fool and
this isn't radio it's a podcast it's
different now now though I'm right now
I'm on the radio hey are you excited I
am I'll tell you why
it's going to play the Sirius XM channel
uh 106 Team Coco radio is going to play
all the podcasts but also there's been a
lot of original content that we're going
to put on there and there's a lot of
stuff from our my many many many years
of making foolishness that's going to
appear on that channel
um and it's been a lot of fun to start
curating things and uh we've done some
you know recordings a lot of recordings
already and it's been I just end up
laughing a lot it's fun so I love the
idea of wasting people's time in a new
creative way yeah that's your real
talent I'm always looking for a new
medium now we've infected what was a
very uh popular and successful
um you know entertainment Outlet yeah
we've uh don't say it like that this is
exciting Sirius XM you know what this
means anytime you rent a car anytime and
you feel like Sona okay I'm going to
trip with my my kids Mikey and Shirley
and my husband Tack and we're in our
nice rental car man I wish I could hear
more Conan yes hold on serious does this
Rental Car have serious I bet it does
most of them do yes it does not
interested yeah I'll just go to 106. and
I traded my car can I trade in the car I
just rent it you have an old Volkswagen
from the six I just want to get a pony
you know one of the fun things is uh
getting to talk to some of the writers
and producers that were there when we
did all this ridiculous stuff that I
don't even remember happening yeah you
have a really big you know thing thank
you very much let's end right there
serious radio has changed you soda yeah
you have this big uh portfolio of work
portfolio I couldn't think of another
one what is the other one
um
hello my name is Conan O'Brien behold my
comedy portfolio wow look at that
throbbing portfolio that hot rubbish
check out my portfolio zip slap
oh my that's some portfolio of comedic
Adventures give me that portfolio I
don't know the thing yeah yeah well it's
a lot of it's a lot of stuff it's not
everybody that's given a full channel on
Sirius XM I looked into it a lot of
people are really yeah
um
no it is it's nice I was excited about
it and and um you know there have been
times I have to admit where I you know
I'm a fan of Sirius xm's and I'll be
listening to you know you listen to like
a Howard Stern or you listen to The
Beatles Channel I really like or I
really like the Elvis Channel
um but then you know I'm like this is
all fine and everything but where am I
and then I think maybe I'm over here no
it's Ozzie's Boneyard you know maybe I'm
over here no it's lithium well where am
I I know that's a very egocentric thing
to say so you were at one point looking
for yourself thinking you had a channel
and you I'm sad to admit I did oh
there's a couple years there where I
would always be very excited
and I would turn to the kids when we
were in a car and say listen to me guys
let's find my Sirius XM channel and it
didn't exist and the kids would then
tease me
but then listen to Aussie
how did I get our own channels too oh
I'm looking into it really yeah they're
gonna be pretty high up oh yeah in the
thousands there's a channels uh very few
people know that there's some serious
channels in the high 2000s yeah the
rarified air it's like a penthouse
Channel yeah I think I could that's what
mine will be program like 20 minutes of
stuff and then that could just be on a
loop if you just played and this is
something we have to do we have to get
your husband's Soviet era toys
children's toys
you have to bring those in yeah and
that's what we could feature on on
Conan's uh Sirius XM channel playing
these toys that tell you to you know
turn in anyone who has strayed who has
strayed from the Communist Party Line I
love a tour where you pull the string
and it monitors you closely and asks you
for your papers yeah my your papers
where are your papers in Russian I have
no idea what it's saying ah here's a
here's a nice little stuffed bear named
who asks you for your papers
[Laughter]
you will come with me now there's
another there's another he has a friend
who's a little rabbit who translates you
must go with you
well anyway I'm Chuck Point Charlie
uh anyway I'm it it is I think we're
gonna have a lot of fun over there so
it's uh if you're inclined SiriusXM Team
Coco radio channel 106 more foolishness
not to be taken seriously but onward and
upward so people are listening on your
Channel right now right now telling them
to listen to your Channel yes they
should check out the podcast this is
like that Escher drawing of a hand
drawing a hand drawing a hand yeah
um yes if you're listening right now to
the podcast and you want to hear more of
me talking you can go to Sirius XM Team
Coco radio channel 106. if right now
you're listening to channel 106 you
might want to check out the podcast
we're every here podcasts are available
and yes all of this will be on vinyl
within the year and then it will be on a
wax cylinder
then they have those Target gift cards
that play little sound bites and it'll
just be one of those I'll cut that that
doesn't work it's not worth it I will
not rest until I'm on a monitor in a gas
station
different times where I've been like
driving through Nevada and I stopped at
a gas station and there's a little
monitor there as I put my unleaded gas
in and it's some
actor or comedian talking to me and I
think yeah man that's when you know
you've made it someday someone has to
look at you wow
and you're enraged at the high prices
I'm Mario Lopez you're paying too much
for your unleaded check out these prices
I'm Mario Lopez and I can't escape this
gas station
I'm actually inside I'm actually in this
tank right now
the fumes are killing me